[Music]  The Voice Blind Auditions continue with  more talented singers and of course more  hilarious coach banter there is  something so classic about her that was  so cool thank you I love your voice I  feel like it has that kind of theatrical  style to it  the coaches absolutely loved 26 year old  hopeful Lilly Pizarro a waitress from  Studio City California  Blake Gwen and Alicia all turn their  chairs but one coach went the extra mile  if you pick me and your call  I tell y'all  Oh  [Music]  what your feelings on your sleeve no  surprise here Lily chose Alicia another  standout contestant 16 year old Savannah  latent uncondition  when in Blake fought over her so badly  Adam Levine couldn't help but call it  like a sporting match with a surprising  move Gwen Stefani taking a look at books  like play chase the lead but maybe  sleeping on the couch tonight  [Music]